What did Bachm want to indicate that
somehow such a food revolution
is taking place in the market? Um, 20 years ago
when you asked applicants what do
they know or what are they interested in?
I think it's so great that
so much is happening in the food market then
you ask which ones  They know innovation
and then nothing happened like that and then when
someone was really well prepared
then the Red Bull said and that was it, yes,
and that's different now, yes, because exactly
as you said before,
the topic of dealing with
food is actually much more
relevant  and we have
seen the market and have
assessed that a food
revolution is taking place and do we want to watch it now
or do we want to be part of it?
Welcome to the OMR podcast
today from Düsseldorf, although actually it
would be more correct because I have been sitting there
for many decades  I think
I have been talking about
the Katches company and everything that goes with it for almost a century or so longer than a century
and
I am a guest of the
two managing
partners
of Kates - one is Tobias
Bachmüller and the other is Bastian
Fassin hi
hi thank you for the invitation although it
is actually your family Mr. fasin
who initiated the company announcement
many years ago you are actually
the bachmü the one who
has been there for a long time no I do
n't think so Fin has been there since 1972 I think
and I he since 1996 okay
So yes, but he was
always interested at an early age, if I can believe his
father, interested very early on, which
means he was
always mentally involved at an early age, but it was
clear from the start that he wanted
a certain amount of training and
foreign experience and studies and
When I came, it was
already absolutely clear that Mr. Fin
would also come to the company if he had
had the experience I described.
It was clear from the start that
their journey together would be
quite long, almost 20  Years, yes, early,
I think 20, that's fine, but very
briefly for everyone who is listening now for the
first time and
wants to understand katches more deeply. I mean, you know
katches from supermarkets, gas stations, parties somewhere,
but it actually didn't
come into being as a candy company;
I think it was somehow around the
turn of the
century around the turn of the century, so I
really searched through history,
so it was effective, so they used to
make pharmaceutical products and also
somehow products to catch flies
and the main problem was just that
Flying only flew in the summer and then
people thought about what should we do in the
winter and then you can
say yes, then the best thing to do is make
neck pastels and then my
grandfather was on holiday in Si
and discovered licorice there and...
saw that licorice helps incredibly well
against coughs and hoarseness and
sore throats and then he
introduced it and I'm
honestly quite happy that we then
focused more on the confectionery business
and less on the rest - the
sugar was a bit of a
connecting element  Glucose and
sugar were the connecting element
because the very special thing about the earlier
fly catchers was that
the glue basically didn't dry so that the
fly always found a hold and, by
the way, that's what we have for all the listeners, we'll
talk about it in a moment, I've
decided  It's better
to do a podcast, which is unusual, the other person
will probably think to themselves just listening to it,
okay, what's going
on, the background is that you say you
also see each other despite
all these 20 years and in general you
explained to me that this is a
production company  and you'd rather see each other
no, absolutely, I always think it's
good, we do things the way it's natural
and if we were to suddenly use first name names
and here Bach and
I would be a bit strange in normal business. W I say hey Tobi, how do you
think  you about it and otherwise never say it
and at the same time we are a
production company 90% of our
employees are employees in the
factories and
it is historical that we
size ourselves and that is why
the same rule applies to everyone and we hope that you are
good with it  get along yes yes I'm
open to everything so that means
so to say genesis understood grandfather
how big was it
when they were born about that's there I
have there I would say
we
made maybe 30 million in
sales yes that  but Mark was still okay,
the hay was relatively small company almost
actually not exactly, you might have to
say my father
was the second-born, my uncle was the
first-born, the first-born
got the company in Holland, what what
you what they spoke to earlier and
my  Father basically
restarted in Germany, so
we started from zero and yes, in the 70s
I would say he made something like 30-40 million,
so I didn't
research it but it was okay in the
order of magnitude and then that's it,
so to speak  We're talking about the 70s
and there's been incredible growth to this day
and I have the feeling that
it has a lot to do with them.
Mr. Bachmüer came in at the end of the 90s,
yes, 96, and then it started. It has something
to do with me, but  As
I said, we have been doing this together for the longest time since 2004,
um, and actually the biggest growth,
we are
what is always preached in management books
but is rarely practiced.
We are a dual leadership,
um, which is actually cool, also cool
for an interview that
relaxes us  Did you come here?
I mean, actually, I would say a relatively
classic curriculum vitae, not a
family member or never been, but
yes, I
was lucky
enough to be born late from her
Father was already 65
and because of the partnership agreement and so
on there had to be a bridge in there and
that was I was previously the boss of Meka
in Germany so I had a classic
employee ver is looked up
absolutely and then they were spoken to.
Then my question was why should
I do that, the answer was because I wanted to get
shares mm and that
also happened step by step. I first had
five, then I had ten and then came
another step, perhaps the
most important one, that I
can also pass them on because otherwise it's like a
stick  option model no, but that didn't
happen until I would say five 7
years later, something like that step by step,
but it's very unusual that
you get involved as an external manager, so to speak,
so I was
surprised to read that, yes, I mean,
I was also pleasantly surprised
yes, but I can perhaps also
say that from the other side.
My father had a clear rule that he
wanted to leave the company at 65
and you start a process like that at an
early age, and he
saw twice that it wasn't
These things worked out and he doesn't like to talk about it that much
and why because he
hasn't found an entrepreneur and it's easy to
say I need a bridge or a
link between them but at the same time
you have to have an entrepreneurial
type because many people say I
am  gerin entrepreneurs but if they
change from the group to another company
then it doesn't work out that way and as
entrepreneurs it's
of course the same for both of us because we both do
n't sleep well when things aren't going well
and we're doing well when things are going well and
of course that connects us  also okay, but what does
al mean, so to speak, is what her
father was also an entrepreneur, so the
second generation, so to speak, but still
at 65 I made the decision
now I would like to
do something else, exactly, yes, I ca
n't, which is untypical for most
entrepreneurs and has many others  Interests yes
also intellectual interests yes it wasn't
the classic one you always imagine it was more like
that
shirt sleeves it was more like well my father was
more of a philosophical type the
best thing for him was reading and
withdrawing and cutting the garden and the
roses so not  So the
classic entrepreneur who comes into the room
says hello, here I am and
everyone follows me, but who
also
came from the product and loved the product and took
forever to ensure
that he got the
best product
on the market and we did  We
also have to differentiate ourselves from the competition. D
came into some markets a little later
than our competitors
and he put a lot of time
into new product development, for example,
and I don't think that
was the classic sales approach, for example, which is not the case at all  would
think and if it was clear to you
that this would now become the company, so
to speak,
then it would become the entrepreneurial task.
I mean,
personally,
yes, I think you grow into a
role like this, that you are then naturally
born and experience everything and then
you first see whether you enjoy it,
it could have been the case that
I simply don't enjoy the topic
and I always enjoyed the
topic and then you grow into it little by
little and I think at the age of 10, 12,
14 you feel it  you then slowly okay, that
could be something and then
a bit of a training path begins that
you think about which path do I have to
take so that it works and that
was also a phase in which I
exchanged a lot with Mr. bmüller and  with my father
so that
he can also say bachmüll what is
required, I also demand, um, because
he doesn't feel like
sitting there with someone who
just looks in the corner the whole time and we've
already discussed something so good
could be gone and it
basically worked out quite well in that direction,
but fun fact they were
also at
Roland Berger's management consultancy for a
while and were there together with
another podcast guest here,
Stefan Teves from Koffeelosen, so who
that  I've also heard that there is a
connection here among the guests in
Germany, new Germany,
so to speak, but then at some point, okay,
advice is out and then just in then
no, I then went to craftfuts, then
worked in marketing and sales and then I closed
Katos came exactly okay so Kat so
to speak in the 70s we're talking 30
million DM in sales then somehow
Mr. Bach she came how much was it
more but not yet
three digits like that and today the order of magnitude
like 800 million you can
say that rffly
couldn't be completely wrong  everything
but everything is pure but it's already a
word so I mean this journey a little bit
I want to understand so how did
it succeed so
people suddenly now have
so much more sweets or what
were the decisions made in the last few
years that led to so much growth
Well, the amazing thing is that
we grow organically and through acquisitions.
Yes, we have the actual
core business, we also
acquired them early on. We bought the ahbrause
or the
wigbonbons, but
fruit gums and licorice are still absolutely dominant in
two thirds and  Of course,
switching to vegan helped us a lot.
We did that in 2010,
before the whole thing with
Rügenwalder and so on came along  It's been
difficult
since then, things have actually been going incredibly
well and getting faster and faster because at the beginning people were
still asking and what was
the next big thing and
you have to say it's getting more and more
we didn't know that back then
basically invented a category because um
no yes so that means purely vegetable
m because we have what was basically the
category of early fruit gums, the
gummy ones always came from
pork gelatine, it can also
be beef gelatine, definitely
animal gelatine and we have
just replaced that essentially with
starch and pectin which is laborious and
Um, I said that at the
works meeting where does
marketing begin? Marketing begins in
the factory because, contrary to what many people believe,
it's not just
nice equipment here, but there has to
be something significantly different at the core, yes and
that's significantly different  We
simply produce completely differently, completely differently. We
even build a
huge new plant every ZD years and it looks completely
different than our competition.
We think that's cool, yes, because that's also
the case when people always talk, yes, and
sustainable and the future is important,
sustainable and  Future
by the way is our biggest
climate protection program because it produces 20% less
CO2 but it is also
sustainable in the sense that the others
can only half imitate it, yes, and
we are blessed with a large number of children,
so four children each,
yes
and that  I'm sure
we're not the ones who say we'll
do it now and then
someone will come and buy it, but
rather we're the ones we want, so we had that
with a standout election or something like that.
We don't want to
be talked to by our children either  What
nonsense are you doing in 10
years? Yes, but it's also the case that
the idea worked out quite well.
I don't think it's that clear to many people
because it's not just about
reaching vegans as a customer target group in addition to them  normal
buyers but also a lot of people
who aren't pigs at all.
The fruit gum category is
actually an exception. In confectionery,
it's actually the only category I can
think of that has meat, so
gelatine is made from pork rinds
and we have eliminated this exception
because many people think so  I don't even think
about it, even those who want it, so it
's a problem for Muslims, for example. Yes, they do
n't know if it was always so
clear to them. We also did this famous
advertisement with the hitchup lady.
Many people thought we just wanted to
somehow annoy the AfD  Complete
nonsense, we wanted to make the point clear
that people who don't want to or can't
eat pork latine or
anything else, at least not in candy, they
can have it in sausage
or something else, that they are our
customers
and that's
just what we didn't want  Just
scandalize, yes, scandalize, but
we wanted to gain additional customers.
What is the product
that most generally
ensures this sales, so with
Katja I ver that immediately with the
yoghurt gams, that is,
so to speak, a yes, but the most well-
known  For vegan this is the
Grünohase as the name suggests yes
I think that is now our second largest
yes yes but we have that's
typical when they go on the shelf
sweets are also there is also selection
and fun we are now not just a
typical nutritional category  but
we are there to bring joy into life, that's
why we need
varieties, that's why we also need
different characters and so on
and we're still doing that, but we
're this idea that started 13 years ago
or something  has never been
more successful than now, yes, you can see that
with the ever shorter
investment steps, it's
actually still a bit surprising
in general that now, in this day and age,
when everyone is talking about health and
nutrition, that you
can grow so much with sweets because
I think  Essentially it's all healthy,
so in our market the market is
n't growing. To be clear, the
consumption of sweets has basically been the
same for 20 years and isn't going
down, but no, it's totally
stable and within this
consumption there's  of course movement from
one manufacturer to another and
there is of course the USB and the
advertising is relevant but it's but it's
almost astonishing when you
look at the time that
everyone goes to fitness and
something else um  that Hal sweets
continue to be consumed in greater quantities,
I mean yes because because people
so it's also amazing why there are so
many types of wine and beer yes
um because people are yes there is a
component yes nutrition and the other
component is also enjoyment and fun yes
and  Because if you eat your diet, I do
n't know how else you eat, but
especially those who always ask these questions,
they all have a dirty
little secret, I mean, I already have
sweets with them and that's a good thing  The
bad thing about that
is like everything else, you can't
eat so much of it, yes, and that's
expressly our wish. Our
children aren't all obese
Next to us everything was
so food-related, yes, the children
came in and I was with Milka, they
practically smeared their whole face,
yes, sensible
behavior, that's part of life and
upbringing, yes, but okay, so it means that
somehow now we won't get it later
To speak, you also do
other things, not just sweets, there are
also cosmetics or such skin care and
so on, but first of all the
business as such with sweets in the
form that it is made is also one that
goes through a lot of trade and in the
end it is like that  It is produced
in your various factories on the
Lower Rhine or a Pozdam is
one, I think, and then you sell it to Aldi
Rewe up and down exactly up and
down is the right one from gas stations
you can also see so yes but that is
not a significant factor  So the
supermarkets are and it's also a
hard life or I mean you hear them
so that they negotiate monsterht
every year they tell you yes that's how it is but
we can do
it on the one hand it's
like that on the one hand  yes, the
consumer who asks for the product and that
is our job, that we do everything to ensure
that he enjoys the product and then
there is the retailer who of course wants
a popular item and
also wants to earn well and our job
is to make sure that he does  Both
does and that's also fair. I mean, how
long can a pack of Jurt Gams be
left at a normal edik market
before there are
problems? So how quickly between
the thing being delivered to the edek until it
goes out, I don't know exactly,
I just know  that because
we are growing so strongly, we have grown by
over 20% again this year, that's
why we work
all Saturdays and, thank God,
with cooperation and with the
workforce, we will
only get out of this difficult situation at the end of next year
when we  We've invested again,
which means we have very low
orders,
so the goods here do
n't get old at all, yes, and the dealer
probably doesn't either. Yes, we
actually have stocks that are constantly too low,
but they say that in the end,
if you listen to it now, the market is  as
such is not growing then it is
also the art of gaining market share
by doing particularly good marketing
and having particularly good product ideas
and so you have to introduce yourself now
or exactly like that and the
second thing is of course that you are
still growing internationally you can
of course move into new ones  Markets go and
of course we also have something with the USP that is
well received abroad then
again to understand this core mechanics
like a
pack of Kaes yoghurt gams that costs in the
supermarket something like two
something no 1 € 99 cents 99 cents a
pack of these these okay and  then there is
the holder and also important and then there
is the dealer's magic
on it obviously that means you have
the 175 g mhm and you have in
the end so I have to be able to produce such a pack
for not know up
to cents  We've
listened to the other podcasts before. It's amazing what
people
say. We've decided
not to disclose the unit costs here,
but you can still talk about everything,
maybe say, about everything,
but not now about our
internal accounting, but
still  What is known about the
industry as a whole, so to speak, is that you
can now achieve a 10% return on sales with the
category of goods you sell, that's
certainly not a wrong order of magnitude,
yes, okay, so you still have to
produce cheaply and that's
apparently the case in Germany  It's
not an issue for you now, so there are
plenty of other products that are
manufactured elsewhere, but you do everything
well in Germany, that's always
a question to what extent does
personnel costs play a role in production
and for us the proportion of personnel costs is
comparatively low because we
are very automated and that's why
it doesn't matter to us and as long as
we can do that we will
of course produce in Germany how many people
work Insam with you so do you
now mean with K my they are with Kat or with
the whole group of the group total
over 2000 now 2000 okay and but that's what
they just said about 90% of it in
production
al okay so then
you try to become independent
it's somehow possible to become independent
from the food retail trade so
we don't want to so there are
already ideas maybe directly
sell a website, yes, we do it, we also
have a shop and are building it
up, of course we also do Amazon and
all sorts of things, but we come
and our main sales intermediary is
the trade and I have the impression that
over the years we have been growing a lot,
that's natural  Also good for
trade, yes that's why we don't get anything for
free, but
we find an agreement more quickly
and we try to do that too. We do
n't see trade as an enemy. I
always read about that, loss of value and blah and
blah, yes we talk the talk to people
with us and somewhere like in
normal life we ​​come to an agreement, we are
distributed everywhere, we are not
listed anywhere, so there has to
be a certain willingness to cooperate
and then
to get into these two value-driving topics, so
on the one hand, new products and on the other
hand, marketing in marketing as I do
I told Kaes here and
everyone said okay, great with Heidi Klumdi,
so now we're talking about the
campaign you did 20 years ago
or something like that. Your employees must
be pretty old, that's true, yes, and but that's where
the yoghurtgams became, so to speak  her
teeth were great, it also
gave us a growth boost back then, yes, but we are
now running a campaign that
we weren't vegan yet at the time,
which is more about it, so the new
claim is who loves animals, the N Kates, to
make the point even clearer and
there  To make it clear in a charming way,
we have now shot the new campaign
on a sanctuary,
of course we also support it and so on so that
it's not just a backdrop,
but as a vegan brand it's
just obvious and that's no
longer as spectacular as it was
When you film with Heidi Klomen, yes,
but it's basically closer to the product
and also more sustainable and how do
you get these messages
to people these days? It's still
television or it's TikTok or where
are you? We're not there at all
no more on TV at all
no not for years yes not in the
smaller markets for years and
this year no longer with
Kates because it's no longer of any use no
we can target better digitally okay
and that means above all  where
tiktok Instagram is different according
to the brands but the category e.g.
influencer according to
Heidi Klum or such big testimonials I
said no, we trust in our
normal campaign, it's also a
bit against the spirit of the times, it
's absolutely different and we do
everything
differently on principle  I have now started with
the sizing
and I have always seen the campaign
with the dog trainer Martin Rütter,
who I know from the podcast, now
has his own product, yes, he invented it and got
in touch with you. Man, yes, really and we
were  immediately, it wasn't that
we bickered about it, but we were
immediately excited, we work
great together with him, the product is also
surprisingly successful, he
really wanted to make a vegan licorice that had
to do with dogs, he also has all the
design, including the shapes and so on  It
's not a fake partnership,
you know W, where we do that and then we
look for names for it, it was exactly the
other way around, he
actually came across it via a podcast where he
said that, he'd like to
do it sometime and then we'll SP on it, of course
dog for his business who had an
idea and some were against it but
I thought it was super original and then
you could create a new sweet like that
with a product like that that
makes millions in sales, okay
crazy so okay the marketing they
also have an
idea  Maybe the hö but now
honestly I do
n't always know whether you do that in the
podcast and
make a deal but we are we are more like
good ideas we are always open to and
we have so we work
great together with Martin Rüter but
really and now  We also started with
Joko,
but because they are
somehow a new type of
celebrities who also have a bit of an
entrepreneurial spirit. Hal,
it's clear that they have that anyway, but with the two of them I do
n't know if you would have guessed that straight away
They then really talk like
a normal entrepreneur. What happens to us
is that we only work in very
small teams, even if from the
outside it looks a bit big with the 2000,
but that means
we can also respond to those who
have  Yes, we don't feel like it, we don't have
1000 hierarchies, yes, but let's be
specific about jokolade, so that's very noticeable
in our scene.
Years ago, Joko invented her own chocolate with the max bitrock
Z from me muesli, and it
was fairly grown
so differentiation I think and of
course then about his his
his name um uh why
is it exciting for you to
do that or how did that come about it came
about about we are involved in
mamüsli and the Philip Kreis one of the
co-founders of mamüsli said
with  Talked to the jogu about it and about
us and since we are sweets,
the closeness was there pretty quickly
and then we met
in my müli rooms in Berlin and we
had a very good understanding right away,
we are 50% involved and  jok yes 50 50
exactly what we think is good because that's exactly
the right way of thinking and what can you do to
help so what do you do what do you
now bring to the table in addition to the cash that
does the thing better than he could have done on his own
so it could be sweet, marketing was
quite good  good and,
above all, we can do
sales very well, so you have the
distribution partnership, we have
a managing director who
used to be a key counter for us, she
can do it well, what I used to
say, you also have to be your job
Simply master
it, yes, and we master the area
well. I mean, it was, yes,
I could also read about it, and it was also a very
quickly profitable company, so Joko
built it up not too
long ago and then there was an article that
I read in advance  In 2021
I think this jokolade company has
noticed annual surplus so notbda
irgas s really hard annual surplus we
also don't like companies that
burn money of 300 you don't have to
be super profitable but you're not allowed to
burn money that's a complete
mistake yes that's what it means but then it has
You can manage that somehow quickly
as a Joko Winter company.
I think we can, above all,
significantly expand distribution okay, okay,
that will be the biggest lever, okay and
then and the second thing is we will, if
you see the package, it says jokolade
on it but  There's no Joko on it and
we're going to change that, yes, what does that mean, there
's no Joko on it, there's no Joko
on it and that's how it's going to be, I don't even know if
this is okay okay okay, that's how it's going to be,
so it has to be on there as a photo
Duff  yes,
of course it's not enough, you have to, you
just have to convert the things into pictures,
so to make a little bit of anticipation for
Joko, I really appreciate him,
so we could use the €300,000
annual surplus in 10
years and you'll be making millions in
results, so that's it  would be a bit
long shocker so that makes it hot
next year millions of results no
but I say I have to
do the result in 10 years I do
n't know that's not how we are at all but we
try and we believe
growth always only begins with
double-digit growth beforehand  Is that
within the range of advertising
price increases and I don't know what, yes,
from double digits onwards you really grow,
we won't be able to do that straight away
but that is the goal of sustainable
double digit growth, yes, you
just said
you're good at confectionery marketing and that
's the core of it  marketing so early on, that's
why we
discreetly placed the marketing price here, what
makes such good marketing, so
that was just a little bit like that,
we do all the platforms well, but
what are the three core things that
you have to do right?  in the
confectionery sector or in general in the FMCG
sector I have already said for Kat
that firstly you need a
distinguishable product, okay what the
others can't do so quickly,
so simple and
can also scale that, that's also something
we do that we can do some of
also vegan fruit gum but they ca
n't produce 50 or 60,000 tons of it now,
yes we have okay so the
product brand is of course that's where it
starts, yes and then you have to
convert it into,
um, the attention that
fits this product and that
's charming  yes, we want to, yes, you need
attention, but you have to
look nice, especially in confectionery, that's why we have
our alpaca on its head
and something like that, that's kiewischel
i.e. a friendly brand and
at the same time we can implement this product feature
well in the foreground and that
our target group in this case is
essentially women who also
find it beautiful and nice and humane, we
might get to it later
what kind of company we generally are, we
want one  Being a company that
is also human, okay, that
ensures that you master these things well,
for 20% growth per year, that
's already good, yes we
grow as a company overall,
we double every 5 years, but that's
of course in that  International area
driven by acquisition we buy
about one company a year because last
year was a bit of a crisis so
we had three opportunities
but yes Haribo does a
bad job no Diemer great job
super job in the end you take it yes Mar yes
that  It's not like it's just
between in the market. We do
n't even look at market shares. We're
just interested in how much we're growing and how
much because market shares. That's simply
a question of definition. What do you put in
the market?
You can concentrate on the confectionery market
on the sugar confectionery market or you can
concentrate on the fruit gum market and
then always choose a share from that and
most people do it that way. They choose
the share where they look best. Yes,
we're not interested. We're
interested. We grow like in the garden. Yes, we wilt or grow  In my opinion,
I don't really care if there's something growing in the neighboring garden.
We were just talking about it in Haribo. They've
been
making gummy bears for decades now, then
they've been making two other categories. They've been
making yoghurtgam for decades, so
to speak as a cash cow as the core product, that's what it's
called  It's not easy to build something completely new, but
you still managed
to make these green-eared bunnies and where is the
next thing coming from? So you sit there
together and think about what's next.
Martin Rüter calls and then
you can tell Joko
I understand that too, but you also
really do your own product development, that you
invent new sweets, so to speak.
How often do you do that? I
think there are two dimensions.
One is that you say I
just develop new products and line
extensions and,
um  and the other question is can I
do something for my existing range that really changes the market,
yes and so, for example, Tesla who simply
says okay, I'm no
longer using a combustion engine but I'm
now going to go electric,
so we basically see innovation
is best, of course  Innovation if
you do that for your entire range,
so that was the vegan idea, that
was exactly that, that's what I think
there is, there's the leverage for you
to introduce a new product as a markamrüsten and
until the new product becomes big, that takes time,
even if you're honest  Years and if
you have an idea for your existing brands with
which you take all the products with you,
it is of course always much larger but there are
still so many things that we have
so we have our brands that are
all unique as a segment, yes of
course there are others too  They
make vegan fruit gums but mostly it's
10 or 20%, but with us
you know everything, no matter what you grab
from Kates, it's always vegan. Yes, the
second one is wig, yes there are other
mentol candies at wig, but so are
all wig products  It's logical that it
comes from wg originally and we always use
mentol, even if we're
doing it now or something like that, the
last thing is also with mentol because mentol
simply reflects this basic promise from wig
at ah brarause there's
no other shower we have
Nowadays, there are also
chewy sweets and all sorts of things, but
we are alone with this
product feature, and that's where
the marketing starts at the bottom in in this case in
Remshalben near Stuttgart. Yes, we always want one of those, what
Mr. Fin said  Eh,
promote basic properties and then it does
n't matter to us whether one product is
better than the other, yes you are a
little happy about new products too,
but the consumer has to
have orientation and understand a brand as an
overall promise, it will be
in the future  Not in spite of that,
so you now live from brands,
say for yourself, it's total brand biness,
so
the barriers to entry are
no
longer that big these days because some
people are now succeeding at it, now Kim Kardashian or
even German influencers themselves
Yoko also managed
to make a new brand popular quite quickly. If we
look at it now, we are running into such an
influencer period that has
n't really arrived yet. There are now
big US examples that are also becoming
bigger and bigger in Germany, the prominent
social media personalities  and you can
already see what they can sell in terms of iced tea and
pizza and other things, some of it is
not sustainable, but
you can already imagine
that everything will get better in the future and that then
individuals could succeed in
creating really brutal new brands
At almost no cost to you
personally, it's not a
huge risk for you that in the future you'll
say yes, we'll be marginalized because
people come here and just have such
a strong personal brand, no, we've
been living in this time for a long time, that
's it  Ultimately, people are
brands and stand for something, yes, and
we've been living in this time for a long time and that
's completely normal in every market,
but to some extent we're working
together right now, so we definitely believe in it,
yes, but that's not either  or but
that is and but it is
already felt in this area that there is
suddenly a skims, this brand of which
many brands are dying,
but they just don't have something like that, they just have
a bit of a
bye, I think there is  two
things, one is that it
becomes a product in
the first place that allows someone to come onto the
market and if you of course say
an iced tea, an iced tea is totally easy to
get so you can mess around everywhere and everyone fills up an iced tea  First of all,
if you have a product
that not everyone can produce and the
second thing is that as a brand offer you have to
leave this gap and our
aim must be that we
are so up-to-date and play on such interesting
topics that we can  Basically, an
influencer can also come, but that
we cover the same topics and
that we are so current as a brand, so
I think it's a product page and also
a brand, it has to be more of a challenge for us
that we also
address the topics, I would say
are as modern as the coolest influencer. I know
that's super difficult for you
because they have a person who is much
more lively, tells a better story,
I don't know who the person is,
okay, I would have the feeling that if I
looked at your company now that would be my
strategic one  Worry, maybe one day
people will come and say I do
n't have any marketing costs anymore,
I'm simply huge with
my reach now, I'm also cool somewhere
and not since
yesterday, I have sustainability
and I'll look for someone to buy
my sweets  produced the way I would like
it to be and then I'll shake
up the market and push you back
and I tried to explain that
you first have to have a product or
have a range that is permanently different.
I think that was also an
attempt  In contrast to
iced tea, we always try that and it
's totally iced, so I
really appreciate it but it's easy. There's
sparkling water with flavoring or
sparkling water with tea and flavoring that's really easy and
anyone can fill it for you, I mean  There are
no mineral wells in Germany, I don't think there are hundreds of them, yes, and that's
why it's just no, it's not that
easy, it's also much
more complex, there are a lot more fixed costs and there are also a lot more
fewer capacities in the market, but for
us the reason is the basic issue, first of all,
the product has to be so complex  It's
not that easy to copy that,
so that means your fashion
is not just the brand S, but also
the production process and the
manufacturing, the whole thing. Yes, we'll start with that
sounds very old-fashioned, but we'll start
with the product and the product  has to
differentiate itself, the product has to be
difficult to produce and then
build on it, of course it makes a lot more
sense to invest because then
I can defend it for a lot longer. I
mean, what you're already
doing successfully now is that you're
buying way too many
established ones  Brands that are, so to speak,
already 40 or 50 years old
in Germany abroad, I
just wi said them, but there are
a whole series of some that
didn't even tell me that they were from Holland
or France, I think
what are you looking at?  So when do
you buy so first look at
brand strength secondly we look at the
category whether it is interesting yes of course
we
look first at fruit gum so the
first big acquisition was the number 2
in France
LTI and that was a company that
also made  Still private label and made a lot of
hard candy and we
then concentrated on yikes because it's
a growth category, it's that
simple, but they did
n't do it before, they had several previous
owners um and um I'm now taking the
most recent example where we from Nestle
Bübchen so
bodycare that's a great category
so something new for you ne bodyc absolutely
absolutely we didn't really know whether
it would work but we needed something for
drugstores because after we bought wix we
couldn't buy any more cough mommungs and
so in drugstores the limited  We
wanted to get bigger and that's what
happened,
um, and we managed that quite well.
Yes, of course, we
immediately took a slightly more aggressive
competitive stance
because we just ran a campaign.
Petroleum, no thanks, because we don't
have any paraffin. Paraffin is what
tea lights are made of  and the biggest
competitors have it, you
may also know a little bit of a
pattern of how we
proceed by distinguishing through a positive characteristic
and that is also a
secret to you, yes, that others just
put it on the baby,
yes, that's what you mean  But that takes time
until the awareness is there, there will
also be legal
disputes, we know everything about
gelatine, yes, but then we'll go
through with it and we are deeply
convinced that our product is the better,
yes, and we're trying to make that clear
Doing that means page Playbook
also means saying something about the positive
properties that your products have and
then
setting things aside. For
example, we have
all the packs or the S,
mostly on plastic bottles with
Bübchen in them, we all have to
switch to recycled plastic
continue to be plastic because a lot of them
are liquid and of course you can
pack them with bad cardboard but by the way
the displays are made of recycled cardboard yes
we try WE is clearly the
target group that does this who has a
huge interest in sustainability W I
just gave birth to a child
Yes, I look at my counterpart now, I
have that too and that's what we do and
we do it in search of
differentiation in search of the
future but also out of deep
conviction who we've already done all of this with Kat
we come into a new company like this,
yes different field, maybe something different
most of the time it's always the first
thing we do is kick people out we never
look for contrast mostly people yes we
have a different approach because we
don't need an exit like a private
equity after 5 years  we do
n't need an exit at all
or or we talked about it
we have if we have another
exit yes yes as I said before
our exit is the
children yes so we have to
talk again about how things will
continue so to speak I wanted to do it again too
That's what they told me in the preliminary conversation,
that it
's the same with takeovers that you look at
what can you take over in a car out way,
car from what is cut out somewhere else
because it doesn't work there, that
comes to you and then you get
it  It's usually very easy for the
big corporations, whether it's Nestle where
we bought Bübchen from or wix
Bonbon from BRT gamel or we
bought Jens the toothpaste from henel, they
all go to international brands, it
makes total sense for them too and such a
regional one  I'll take
Bübchen as the market leader in Germany but
nowhere else is irrelevant for someone like
Nestle and doesn't have the
necessary attention and it's also completely
right to simply have different priorities
and that's exactly what we specialize in.
You then hear in the scene that something
isn't going well  right and then the
Z listener grabs hold of it. Yes, we often go very
simply through interviews.
A lot is often revealed in interviews,
almost more so than in a
podcast, and it often says in there that
these national brands maybe think about
blah blah and then  Let's go and
is there another category conceivable for you
now next to my line
describe say all of a sudden
care products Bübchen and sweets is
coming something
third could be could be
but must be a very great brand we
come always go from the brand
which segment would be good where  where would
you do something else? I don't think we
're there at all. They expect us to
be so strategic that we
analyze these segments and say that this is
now a growth segment
consumer good
then we look at it so
basically it has to be a brand that
had a great history it has to
be Fast Moving Consumer good and then
that fits into our scheme and then it's
basically similar. Many people always think
marketing Bübchen would be so total
Unlike Katja's marketing, the
basic tools are the same, the
seller at the end is the same, the
trade, the consumer is a similar one
who only thinks in different
categories once he reaches into the or
deck category, but otherwise it's
not that different, I think what
we're talking about  would never have the confidence
to sell cars or machines somehow,
yes that would really be too
far, but Fast Moving Consumer good
as a term that fits. I would have always
thought that companies like yours
would have a bigger problem the moment
television advertising no longer
works that way  Because you
can no longer build up brands like that with such a simple fixed price, you just have a
CPM on television and you'll be
shown there millions of times and then people will buy
your things in grocery stores and then
the retailer is happy and then they buy  After
the system is now disrupted at the moment
when television advertising no
longer works as well as it used to, you can even figure it
out yourself. Um, the fact that you
can now use digital to build up sales pressure as much as you
need it surprises me, but you've
just  yourself the best example,
you brought the influencers and
said that today they are bringing brands onto the
market that have never done TV advertising
and they are only available through the internet and
yet they can even establish a brand,
why shouldn't we
do it that way too because they do  Generation
influence that we were talking about at the moment,
funny enough Joko Martin Rütter, they
also grew up on TV so they
themselves are good point but that
's just the digital possibility, it
's basically about
creating awareness in a specific segment
and I think it's the other way around  You have
a lot more waste through TV. I
think the
barrier to entry into the
consumer goods market through TV was much higher
in the past because you first had to be
able to run a campaign of X million.
Today with online and digital media
you can reach a top target group much
better, but I do  It would have been
much more expensive for you because you
now have to bid for the contact in the auction process on
Instagram and TikTok everywhere
and you are competing
not only against other haribus in the
world but also against
any travel providers or companies
that want to do something completely different with
them  Contact and that would have to be
the indirect question about the
cost structure and and we're a
bit
cautious about that, yes, okay, but I think
the theory is like that or I think it's
a mistake if the theory is like that then
the theory is so good okay okay  I'm
just taking it with me, so at least I
have a gpan harib, they're doing a great job,
but I also
took a look at it in preparation. I
was very surprised, it's around 3
billion in sales, you're now saying something like 800
million, but since the last one
We've
talked about it for years now, growing something in the double digits
to 800 million,
but with a lot of acquisitions and
they haven't done that, but
you have to say they're completely
constant at 2.8 2.9 I think that's what they
are too  grown but not so
much yes yes they also had a
higher base before it's the same way let's
if you want information about Haribo
F with the interview I can we can
say from our own perspective that it's a great
store that is well managed that they build
also systems and when someone
builds systems it always shows that they are
doing something right. I would have
only thought that they are significantly larger
because I was traveling in the USA in the summer
and
suddenly the Haribo is lying around even in their small shops in the USA
Is there finally something from Kata's
good question? We're building now, especially
when we have capacity again, then
we can sell more again. At the
moment we're
also sold out, so you could say that
's really cool and there are
no partners that you can work with, so to speak
other manufacturers
who produce for you, you
do it yourself, absolutely
we are, we totally believe in production,
we did things differently with sweets at the very beginning,
so when we
took over the first brands, we had it
produced externally and we
also thought we would do it  Now,
like Nike, great marketing, great sales,
but we have learned that if you
produce it yourself, you are simply closer
to the product, yes, and um, many people don't do it
and they still try to do that today,
but um, this proximity to the product and the
production process makes it possible  To
simply be more innovative,
you still produce, so to speak, as a
white label for retail, so to speak, that you have
things from yourself under yes, a
small part but that is under
10%, well under 10%, which means in the end
your challenge is
to release cash again  then to be
able to build systems in order to
expand your production, exactly the
cash is there, but the systems
just take longer to be delivered
and once that's finished then
you could also imagine that you
actually go to the USA, maybe
yes  you, that's not the case now, we're going to
grow internationally, we're
also growing very strongly internationally, absolutely, and of
course you can do that, but more in
Europe, yes, and of course you approach it market by
market, and now you have to
basically, um, our story from Germany
too  tell about it abroad because it is
just as relevant, okay, what are the other
markets that you look at, so
what are the big markets
for us? England,
Holland is a big market for us, the
German-speaking countries are
a big market for us and the other countries
As you know, at kte
international we are also local
with like we are France with a
brand we are Italy with a brand
so I would say we are
now very well
represented in Europe and I think you can
also  You can invest
in an indirect way, so to speak. In order to
finance the entire growth, the
acquisition and plant construction are
not only made from the cash fow from the end
result in Germany, where we
build all the plants, which is quite normally
financed conservatively with high equity capital from the bank  And from the
main shareholder,
yes, there are no
bonds at Kat international Kat
greenf, there are bonds because we take it as an
acquisition. It's always
difficult to finance otherwise, yes, because
it's abroad and so on.
You can't come in here with the savings bank
Make measurements where we usually
mainly
work together and
anline is basically credit, yes, we
've been doing it since 200 11 have
now refinanced for the fourth time,
so for all listeners who aren't very
familiar with anlei, you end up giving it to
private individuals too  I can go to the
bank and say I would like to
sign the KTIS international bond, which can
be obtained from 1000 € and that is
currently available, I think, at just under 4%.
No, it was before that, unfortunately the interest
rates have gone up  So
you
then also for the investors
we give you the money and you then use it to buy
these companies in z.  and we have to
hit the 6inhb% with the results, that's what we do, what was the
biggest deal that we've ever done there, in
terms of
volume, yes, I would say, wait a minute, where
did we pay the most in Italy when
we bought Lari, what do they produce?
make sweets, also make fruit gum
sweets
are very strong in the Christmas business,
so Torone doesn't know if everyone
knows that, yes, that's a white nuger
typical in the southern countries.
We have just
bought a pannetone factory there, but they are
always brands and are market leaders too
in the Christmas business in Italy
yes, that was our biggest acquisition to date,
yes you have to say and you always pay your
segment something like 10 to 12
times the profit of a company as a
purchase price you generally pay yes yes of course you
love a little less,
I know that but
that  It's often not that easy,
what do you pay for, what stocks are there
or something like that, it's not always very
clear that with Joko, let me
do the math for a moment, with an
annual net profit of 300,000, that would have been
3.6 million that Joko would have  That
the base is already low, so
maybe you are such good friends with Joko,
you should better
not ask him about
us, but the Jokolade was still worth a few million. That has to be
said, I think that's
absolutely unsound and about that
To extrapolate, I know that's
probably not a favorite topic of
yours, but for the company, let's
take sales times 10% return, let's say quite a
bit 80 million times 12, then the
company value that's here would be almost a billion,
probably even more
because the growth is great  and then
we're not interested in that,
really zero, yes, we're
not interested because it's at the end like we
said, we want to pass it on to
the children at some point, which doesn't matter
that we have great brands in the
company because brands
also create a certain level of security
and the second is that things are simply
going well and that is why
we are growing and that is why the
second question is always monitoring, it is
not just simply n EBIT multiple,
but the question is whether the store is growing
or declining  yes, also an
important evaluation criterion from abol
that's why I have this one
billion valuation is very conservative
because with the growth you have
and head over it, no, that's why
I think it's just important for us
that we show we're growing and this
growth and  We'll hand these brands over to
the children at some point, whether we're doing
can we still develop? Yes,
that's what drives us:
what can you do, what are the
opportunities? You have to measure yourself against that, you do
n't have to measure yourself against some
fictitious value, but rather how good
you are, what you can do and what you can do  You can
design it, it's great and I mean you
have a company for this purpose,
the CTI greenfood, which is the third pillar
in addition to the core business and the
German business and then
internationally with all the
acquisitions and then as a third there
is participation in it where
you too  Just a few percent
belong to the oat card, I've seen my
muesli now since new
and you don't want to
act like a venture capital F and say let's hold the D for 4 5
years and then sell it with a profit, we do
n't want to have to  but
sometimes because if you are a minority
you can't decide on your own,
but very often there is a so-
called
telong clause in it, which means that
if the majority owner has to defend,
we have to sell,
we haven't had to sell at the same time, but of
course that can always happen, but that's
our intention  Isn't it, we are
not a fund, that's the first thing and the fund
takes in other people's money and has to have a
certain level of profitability, we don't
want the brands to
develop well because of us,
we want them for a very long time and if there is always an
opportunity  then we
usually try to buy z and what what
fascinated you about may muesli what
you got into muesli a few months ago with 10%
yes fantastic brand
fantastic brand
we think we always go for great
brands and this is one of the brands that
Everyone knows in Germany and almost
everyone likes them, so a little bit like
the principle of von lwm Asch in the
fashion sector, so where the Bernese anoda
also said, somehow I buy all luxury brands
and so a little bit
you are there, so to speak, for yes in this
case  At greenfood it's about
us buying so-called future food, so these
are vegan brands or
we bought flood-free bread, yes,
and muesli fits and that's
organic muesli, of course it fits perfectly in there.
Have you followed
what Frank Telen did, he was
on the podcast  and I'm
pretty impressed too. I can say a lot
critically about him, but what he's
created with all the
food brands, i.e. with Ankerkraut,
the spices or with the wfood or
with this airup, these drinks, they
're all
very valuable within a short period of time  Companies have also become
partly visible that through the sale
you have seen it, you have also been a bit
inspired to say what is currently
happening in the food sector in general,
so first of all he is doing it really
well
and with us it was like that, what we also
saw is what Bachm is suggesting
wanted a food
revolution to take place in the market somehow,
20 years ago when you asked applicants
what do they know or what are they
interested in? I think it's so
great that so much is happening in the food market
then you ask what
innovation do you know?  and then
nothing happened and then when someone
was really well prepared then the Red
Bull said and that was it, yes, and that's
different now, yes, because exactly as you
said before, the topic of
dealing with food has
actually become much more relevant and
we have  We saw the market and
assessed that there was a
food revolution taking place and do we want to
watch it or do we want to
be part of it and that's why we
founded the Kates greenfood and
decided that we would like to invest in great new
concepts that would simply change the market
because when you have an oat hangover you feel it
right now that's just great because
you have system catering where you
eat absolutely sensibly, yes, take a
porridge with nuts on it, fresh
applesauce that you made yourself, tastes
good, is healthy and
you don't have to eat a sensible diet  to the bakery, which is
on every corner and that
excites us when someone really
changes a market like this completely and when you see it like that, you also see
how much change is happening in the
food sector
and how much expertise you have there
tries to say everything
we have to do is we have to work hard
from the cash flow, we have to
issue bonds with 6% interest and so I think there
are also options, say we just
give 20% to the stock market and
get a lot of cash or
to some fund or something and then
you would have many more opportunities to
participate in this current trend. I don't think that
our growth through capital is now
restricted, but rather
that there are opportunities and that there are
further ideas for
companies  Buying isn't
just a matter of going through the counter
and saying, I have a check here now
and selling it, but there has to be
options and I think
everything that has been offered to us
so far, which we find very interesting,
we somehow have
I don't think capital
is the problem, do you feel the economy,
so now everyone is talking about the recession in
Germany, that's what you're seeing, we do
n't feel it at all, it's
also the case that we're more of a
comparison of the economy-independent
category with food  This
also means that we don't have the huge hype
that other industries have,
but for us it's more of a
stable business
and we don't feel it where we
felt it or where the market as a
whole felt it was of course
inflation that the raw materials were all  have increased immensely
and that we
had to deal with the topic, but then
we also decided that we would
somehow
swallow a part of it ourselves and
then pass on part of it and thus continue to
have a very fair price in the market VI
makes  you have a job like that now you are now 66
yes so the statutory pension starts
next year yes but I'm
not in retirement at all I'm an
entrepreneur and self-employed I'm
not in the pension insurance
so unfortunately nothing starts for me
so unfortunately or God  Thank you or no, it
was a joke, but you do it as
long as you can do it well, so yes, and
I don't have anything about the saying
stop when it's at its best, that
's the stupidest saying in the world,
no footballer would say that, yes, and I do too
not but but at some point you will
of course become weaker and slower
or something like that but that's no I have
the feeling it's still at least
5 years away I don't know you should
n't like that the people who start out and
say they know exactly what they're doing
Doing 70 or 75 is an exaggeration,
but I'll give you a deterrent example.
I'm sure I won't live to 90 like some others.
Okay, and there's already a next
generation, so someone will
probably look at it
then. You have to say that not
all eight children will be  then come over to the poor
company but there would be two coming
yes that and they will all be well
trained hanfasin's daughter is currently
at Harvard you can see that
there is talent there is talent there is yes yes
so I think we are doing um at the moment
I think it's still
good and we can do it for
a few more years and then
at some point the children will grow up and if they
are well trained then it's
the natural way that they will
take it over and probably
make it better at some point  When we are,
at least when we are of that age,
Mr. Scholz was recently
a guest. Yes, I want another successor.
That's important to me again, since we
are a dual leader, the
question is not as extreme as in
other companies  There is such a core figure,
yes, and there where
pressure builds up at some point. Yes, we work
together and I'll say that if I do
n't take the lead tomorrow, the
company will continue. Yes, that's not
the pressure, it's just shared, yes and  That
reassures me, yes, I can't understand it,
but very briefly, how does the
Chancellor get to you? Yes, we have a large
factory, our sweets, which are salos
or wig sweets, which we make in
Potsdam. We have built our own factory
for them because they are a completely different kind
is to be produced and that is
a constituency and the directly elected
representative is the Federal Chancellor aha
so a very special constituency and
he then does quite well like
a really, really zealous
representative who goes on a summer trip
and in his constituency and visits
various companies and there  He's
one of the bigger ones, he
also visited us and
probably asks a little bit about what you
want or what you
need and the opportunity that was
actually he had his two
constituency employees, not the one
from the Chancellery, but the one there on
site  are there and we had
the
plant manager and the
works council chairman and what did
they want so what do you want
from the Chancellor because
we don't do it that much,
many companies think that when the Chancellor
comes they have to make themselves big
wish something or say something, really express your
opinion and things like that, we're happy to see him
as a guest, we're happy to talk to us
and he was.
That sounds a bit strange now,
but a completely normal person also
told us how he used to be a labor lawyer
and where he also had contact with the trade
I think it was somehow
a trading cooperative where he also
worked. That was interesting and
we talk about how we
do business and since we're not that common over there, we're
fully bound by collective bargaining agreements, we
also pay several above-tariff bonuses
and constantly hire new people
Um, I'll say I think he
rather liked it, yes, what is your
entrepreneurial view of Germany?
I mean, if you now
think in the long term in the sense of we're
actually just keeping them warm for
the next generation,
then you have to  have a high level of
trust in the core country in which
the company is located, is it like that or are you
a little worried? Yes, we're
not worried at all, so we
think Germany is a big
country and we've seen many companies
abroad and that's why  You do
n't spend a lot of time abroad and when you
come back to Germany you always say
it's not that bad,
yes, it's always like that when you're
just in your own tunnel,
sometimes you forget what it
actually looks like, but I mean
No matter where in Germany we can
go to the hotel, unpack our jogging shoes, go
out the door and
jog around in how many countries can you
do that? Yes, we have a
tax system, which I think is fine because
somehow everyone has to pay taxes and
keep this place running
I also think it's a good thing we have an
education system that everyone always complains
about, but in many other countries there
is an education system that
is really bad and the other one can
only be afforded by a lot of people with a lot of money
and we don't have that in Germany,
we have great ones  School system, we
have great highways, we have a
functioning ST, that's why I think
it's a great country, but we have to be
careful that we don't talk it down anymore,
that we're
making ourselves smaller and smaller, yes we are, I
'm absolutely happy in this country and
I'm happy too  After every trip
when I come back home or to
Germany, the core argument
that is currently in my field
is the energy costs according to the motto,
we have lived very well for years
because we can buy energy so cheaply,
that is now over and
Now the industry will also migrate
and then it will be really problematic. I
mean, you have a proximity to
energy costs. In your case, they are
probably not as important as they are
in chemistry or something like that, but there is a little
something there too, so that's not a
problem  Energy costs are
also an issue for us, which we have to
deal with again now and have to
find solutions, but I'll put
it this way if you're being completely honest,
we also lived a bit on the credit of
this world,
we got gas cheaply
that everyone is blowing up the CO2 going into the
world and they said that it's all good,
and now I think it's a
bit fast. I sometimes think it would be
good if it were a bit slower,
but the basic approach is that because
it all used to be like that  It was cheap
but basically it was miserable for the world. It
can't be that things
have to continue like this and the other thing is, I
think we Germans have
always managed to get things done well somewhere, even with perhaps
difficult conditions,
if you look at them from afar and
you can see that  they have high wages
because they have so everything in itself is
difficult the country shouldn't
function at all and the store is running great why
because somehow things
get better and that has to
be our claim because
we get by with Z through scaling
Of course not in a small country, so education is
probably a core asset, yes and
I think that's great. We like being
entrepreneurs in Germany and are also
optimistic about the future. Yes,
I like that because I think that's
definitely the case in many rounds of discussions
and talk shows  you
doubt everything and say it's just that we're
facing really big problems, yes you
have to be purely factual, yes
maybe there's an issue here and there if
you look at the numbers all together
and everyone said we
now have a huge issue  in
Germany and then it goes
up or down around 03 or 04, that's not great, we
have to grow more and we also have to
create the conditions for it, but it
's now a
complete catastrophe
and that's how it's always portrayed, that is,
we are much more positive and I
think  I'll use that as an
example, we still have a great
middle class, we have a huge
middle class, nowhere in the world is there
so much middle class, but what do we have,
our garden in many other
countries, four large tulips grow there and
that's the industry and here  It's
a garden full of flowers, it's
wonderful and you just don't know exactly
which flowers will come up afterwards, but I
prefer to be in a country where we have a big f
and we also have a great
training system in parts, so this dual system
we train a lot  We think it's
great, absolutely, so our
head of production, he's practically
one after the two of us with the most important
Germany, he started with me
as a trainee
and then worked his way up, it's great
because in general, I mean, we're also
very networked in German medium-sized
businesses  You probably know
a lot of other business families, that
's generally the
case and that you ask them a lot now and they also
talk a lot and in general maybe the
view is more positive than you
might think based on the fs.
I think the mood is so
average, yes  We're
rather different, yes, I think the mood
is so average, so industries are also
different, that's why I want to go there too. Of
course, I see it from
our
perspective now, but the world is also a
bit like you see it and and
if you look at it  If you say everything is bad all day long
then it is bad
and if you
tell yourself everything is good every day then it will get
better. D it will be bad and
not good yet but you have to condition yourself a little bit,
you are
actually afraid of  Regulation I think
we have now experienced that say what has
happened so gradually in the tobacco sector over the last few decades in the
alcohol sector it is the same and I'm
lazy now but every now and then I read
articles about sugar and so that's
one thing that you  What's more worrying than
other things is that it's much more complex, no,
with alcohol it's very easy to have
a neurotoxin and with cigarettes it's
also very easy that it's
carcinogenic, but food is
much bigger, so you want to
say now that meat is allowed in the future  There should
be no more Bernais sauce and the
pomfrit, they also have to
be abolished and you can only
drink water. I believe that what there has
to be is that the consumer is
offered a wide range of products, that he
can buy A B or C and then that
decides but if we  we got so far
that we had a standard toothpaste again
that was distributed to a part of Germany,
er after the war, I think it's
not okay, but I mean it
's somehow when you
try to grab this company now, you
think that maybe they are  The
risks then would be one that
occurred to me, I think that there we see, I do
n't think there is any risk, I
definitely believe that it is a good thing
if you give people a choice and don't
ban it. I don't think any party in
Germany will be successful as a
ban party
Some parties are currently having an experience,
yes, I know who you
mean, now I've tried to
build up TV advertising influencers as risks, now regulation has explained it to you,
but what are the risks, so
if you say that they aren't, I
now also understand that there is big
business  WAG
man, there are all these risks that you
mentioned, it's true that they
all exist, but they aren't any that
really scare us or for the future
of our companies, so we focus
on them like bad weather, yes there will
also be more heavy rain  Speaking of which, yes,
we do, it's always a medium
between moving forward,
accepting things and
adapting, yes, and we adapt
when the time comes, but
we're directly concerned with the future of our company
I'm afraid because it's now active in so
many fields, that makes it
just like this table, it does
n't just have two legs, thank God,
but a whole row of three, so it just stands
firmer. Yes, that's a
hassle that we have  I
think the biggest risk
I see is that we as people and
as an organization no longer
have the claim to be successful and
want to continue, that's a big one if you do
n't know what to do anymore  not W slacks
yes that's just cruel you that's
the biggest risk that you do
n't want as an organization and
I don't see that as a risk honestly
not because we are that can all
confirm that those who start here have
first of all they're always surprised
how  ambitious we
are speed but what I want to
say is that it's up to you, it's up to you, it's up
to the organization, it's up to the
company and the challenge
you have to manage, so I see the
biggest risk that if we get bigger and bigger,
that we won't be like that anymore
have the same human spirit
that we have now that's the
biggest risk in my opinion yes there are Steve
Jobs stay hungry stay foolish we would
say stay hungry stay human
yes that's more important finding the balance
you have internal goals so
now  I just heard that somehow you
didn't reject
the 8 million that I estimated,
so now I'm not totally
crazy to say that next year or the
year after that you'll make a
billion in sales, for example, or
maybe even in 10 years you'll make
two  or no idea, yes, that
's not totally crazy, but it's
irrelevant to our thinking. Maybe
you can do that with this
J, for example, we try ours that you
add the whole numbers and then
it all sounds like a big deal
and we share that  In
our company, each company has a lot of small units,
between 100 and 150.
Now we're bringing them together a little differently,
so it can
be twice as big and all of these
units
are managed by a
managing director. They're a holding company
and in the same way Kat here
we are operational and then there is the Kat
international in the holding company and
underneath there are individual companies and
each company is basically a
bit like its own family, there
are always 4,500 employees and when
we say stay
hungry  stay human then it means we
just want to continue to
be in contact with people. I was at
the works meeting at ubrau yesterday and
discussed topics with the employees and we want to
continue to do that, it's not a big plant, there
are 60 people somewhere in it  The valley behind
Stottgart, yes, but there you can see what
involvement is behind it and can you
still grasp it all? The
challenge of
internationalization is also the
question of where are they going now?
you we lead we now lead here
at Katja with both sales and
marketing, this is a
production location
and you just have to
give people security and they
also have to see you as an entrepreneur and
also see where the future is going and if you
If you say that and say it personally, it's
different than if you write or
do a video conference. We believe that
stay human means from human to human
and not from laptop to laptop
never one so that means 5
days a week people always come but they
see that yes that's normal that means that there are
always two or three teams per brand
yes and
they also have a lot of space and a
pleasant environment we are renting
more and more here too because  It's important to us
that people feel comfortable
but that they communicate directly with each other
and that's why the
versin goes to a
works meeting in Stuttgart, yes
who does that a lot more than if he was there I
say I know that from the company
he will then use a video screen
faded in I greet everyone so so yes that
's nothing yes we believe
absolutely from person to person and we
also like to go to the customers
I can confirm I think someone
thought about doing the recording remotely
and they said no no
If we don't do that
then the Wester has to come here, yes
it has another other Fler, we
believe you even if the Bachmer says
we always offer offices here, what he
wants to say is that they are old, all
individual offices, we have h  A lot of people
always say yes, take it, but
this is an open-plan office where
you can all sit together. We don't want that.
We think it's great if everyone in
your team is in an office where
you feel comfortable and not like
a telephone operator  In addition to the
other one and a half meter board, that
also means you have the idea of ​​economies of scale
that you say okay, I'm now trying
to scale certain things here with all the acquisitions, you don't do that at all,
we don't centralize anything either,
okay, that's not even IT, okay, okay
Okay, we don't believe in synergies,
we believe in entrepreneurship. Yes,
we believe in synergies in the market. Well,
you're actually like an investment
holding company with operational business, but
not in the
core business, the overall trend is
no longer in Silicon Valley when you read that
They're almost all
back to the central office but no matter
even Zoom I've now read it
F I'm
cool we
think this basic trend is more
home office
m less travel
and fewer social events we do
the opposite of everything yes we do
n't have a home office at all we  encourage everyone
to travel as much to customers to agencies to
importers even from the lowest
grade yes and to find the personal exchange
and we do it all the time almost
probably some of them go to
social events yes whether we
have a family celebration
or housewarming here next door
or  Christmas dinner and so we have the
full program yes that's where we are we're
almost there extreme yes so yes
I think a lot of what
we like people to
say briefly and those who are hiding there
we always have the feeling that
maybe people like them too  not so
and so direct contact and so yes so
very impressive I mean that's yes
you say W other a bit also a
counterintuitive approach in some
things that you rarely hear now so
I now have a lot of meetings where people
have argued differently yes mainstream yes yes
yes, very refreshing so s
I'm happy that I can be here
that you can experience and hear like this enriches me
f it's interesting
so I I also think I understood it quite
well so congratulations on the
company of course and thank you very much for that
That's it, so for the time being,
I haven't asked anything yet, what
I should perhaps ask, what
else is on your mind,
you can't
offer more, well, all right, then I'll put
the big K bowl here again,
thank you very much  yes, thank you very much for
coming, everything is clear, ciao ciao ciao
ciao